[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
[Галичина
Львів]
Взагалі, «Dodo Socks» —
це сукупність випадків та випадковостей.
Ми працювали в IT-шці, в офісі...
[Марта Турецька,
співзасновниця «Dodo Socks»]
... в приміщенні,
де також знаходилося виробництво шкарпеток.
І в нас наша компанія,
як і всі компанії в той час,
збирали гроші на АТО.
І нас з Андрієм відрядили закупити
шкарпеток теплих на те виробництво.
Ми зайшли. Раз, другий, третій
ходили докуповувати ті шкарпетки зимові.
І потім прокоментували,
що депресивні дизайни.
Кажемо: «Ну давайте щось веселіше.
Що у вас все чорне і чорне?
І сіре з калиною?
Ну таке воно усе... Нормальне». [Сміється]
І нам тоді директор сказав:
«Так принесіть свої дизайни і ми зробимо те,
що ви хочете.
Шо ви тут ниєте?».
І ми такі: «Вау, ок».
Ми зробили дизайни, роздали друзям.
Друзям сподобалося, ми зробили ще.
Потім подумали: ну зробимо логотип вже,
будемо якусь бірку клеїти.
І так воно пішло-поїхало.
І вже потім в один момент
ми зрозуміли, що ну все вже.
Вже треба або IT-шка, або «Dodo».
Бо два діла суміщати не виходило.
І ми вирішили піти на користь «Dodo».
Ми працювали вже зі Львовом,
з Брюховичами, з Жовквою, з Харковом.
І поки що Рубіжним
ми зараз абсолютно на 100% задоволені.
[Слобожанщина
Рубіжне]
Ми починали з нуля.
Була у нас в місті Рубіжне фабрика.
[Геннадій Місюренко,
директор «Панчішної мануфактури»]
В 90-х роках вона зупинилася.
І роботи не було,
а в мене брат обслуговував ці машини.
Ми купили три машини
і почали цю справу.
Так ми і залишаємося двома власниками: я і брат.
Починали з продажу шкарпеток,
а тоді зрозуміли, що це не наше
і почали виробництво.
Це якось нам ближче духом.
Орендували ми маленьке приміщення,
невеличку кімнату близько 20 квадратів.
Він в'язав, а я оверлогом зашивав.
А потім виходив на базар і продавав.
Так ми починали свій бізнес.
Рубіжне? Хтозна-де те Рубіжне.
В Луганській області.
[Роман Шупер,
співзасновник «Dodo Socks»]
Подивилися, ніби ще по нашу сторону.
Ну добре, можна писати.
Ясно, що є стереотипи.
Коли ти проїжджаєш два озброєнних повністю КПП,
ти розумієш, що напевно не просто те все.
Коли в нас питали: а де ви шиєтеся?
Ми спочатку говорили: далеко,
починали на Західній Україні,
зараз вже більше на сході, в Луганській області.
І люди такі: «Ой, а як так?»
І починалася ця тема: Схід-Захід,
там «сєпари», «ватнікі».
[Андрій Плясун,
співзасновник «Dodo Socks»]
Але найбільше про це говорять ті,
хто не був далі Тернопільської області.
Зараз ми вже навіть акцентуємо на цьому.
Що ми відв'язуємося в Рубіжному
і в нас є з ними контракт.
До 2015 року ми працювали
лише на Донецьку та Луганську області.
[Ольга Ушакова,
співробітниця «Панчішної мануфактури»]
Трішки в Київ відправляли, трошки в Одесу.
Але далі Києва ми не виходили на ринку збуту.
Коли вже в Луганську та Донецьку області
ми не могли продавати свою продукцію,
ми вийшли на всю Україну.
І в нас почався дефіцит продукції.
Ми не могли покрити потребу покупців.
Цей момент нас підштовхнув розвиватися,
докуповувати обладнання.
Класно, що в них на фабриці
написано «Рубіжанська панчішна мануфактура».
Хоча, коли він замовляв і робив цю вивіску,
йому мер міста казав:
«Та напиши нормально — чулочна фабрика.
Яка панчішна мануфактура? Що це таке?
Тебе ніхто не зрозуміє». [Сміються]
А Геннадій каже: «Нє-нє, ніякої чулочної фабрики.
Панчішна мануфактура — тільки так».
Видно, що люди дійсно люблять своє виробництво.
Сподобався у них повний контроль виробництва.
Коли шкарпетка виробляється — вони її маркують.
І потім, у випадку браку, точно знають,
хто це робив, в яку зміну, на якій машині.
Відповідно, якщо якийсь брак —
одразу міри приймаються.
Тут от, наприклад, одна горизонтальная лінія.
Кожен станок (в них їх зараз 60,
буде 120)
має свої маркування.
І коли якийсь брак,
або неправильні параметри шкарпеток,
то вони одразу дивляться, який станок
і одразу його ремонтують.
Коли ти виробляєш для них шкарпетку,
ти розумієш, що виробляєш не просто шкарпетку.
Ти виробляєш якусь емоцію.
Вони дуже скрупульозно ставляться
до усіх елементів.
До підбору кольорів.
Змінюють відтінки, змінюють основу.
Вони готові експериментувати.
Мені подобається сама суть того,
що ми — Львів і Рубіжне —
робимо класний продукт.
Ми ніби дві крайні точки України.
І я дуже щаслива з того.
Ми всі дуже щасливі.
Ми хочемо, щоб вони до нас приїхали.
То наш пес — Гаспар.
Він директор «Dodo»
і зробив шкарпетку «Brovko».
20 гривень з кожної пари йде на притулок,
з якого він до нас прийшов.
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Оператори
Павло Пашко, Максим Завалля, Олег Сологуб]
[Продюсерка
Оля Шор]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Звукорежисер
Павло Пашко]
[Монтажерка
Марія Теребус]
[Субтитрувальниця
Варвара Вербицька]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]